REALLY IMPORTANT REPORTING.
THANK YOU FOR THAT.
BRET BAIER.
>> SEE YOU, TUCKER.
>> Tucker: GRETCHEN WHITMER
HAS SPENT MOST OF HER WORKING
LIFE AND THE GRUBBY SMALL
CONFINES OF MICHIGAN STATE
POLITICS.
IT’S NOT A TRAINING GROUND FOR
EXCELLENCE.
WHEN SHE WAS ELECTED GOVERNOR A
LITTLE OVER A YEAR AND HALF AGO,
NO ONE EXPECTED HER TO MORPH
INTO A WIFE AND INSPIRED -- A
WISE AND INSPIRED CHIEF
EXECUTIVE.
WHEN THE CORONAVIRUS HIT, SHE
HAD NO CLUE WHAT YOU SO SHE
RESPONDED WITH A MIXTURE OF
COMICAL INEPTITUDE AND A WEIRD
KIND OF ARBITRARY FASCISM.
SHE BANNED THE SALE OF CARPETS
AND PAINT AND POTTED PLANTS.
USUAL PEOPLE THEY COULDN’T
FINISH OR GO TO CHURCH OR DRIVE
ALONE TO THEIR OWN HOMES.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME, WHITMER
KEPT LIQUOR STORES, WEED SHOPS,
AND LOTTO KIOSKS OPEN BECAUSE,
AND THIS WAS PURELY AN
EPIDEMIOLOGICAL MATTER, IN THE
INTEREST OF PUBLIC HEALTH, THOSE
WERE ESSENTIAL SERVICES, QUOTE.
THEY ALSO HAPPEN TO PROVIDE
MASSIVE TAX REVENUE TO HER
GOVERNMENT.
THE WHOLE THING WAS RIDICULOUS.
IT WAS JUST A MATTER OF TIME
BEFORE THE PEOPLE SUFFERING
UNDER THIS INSANITY SAID
SOMETHING ABOUT IT.
YESTERDAY THEY DID.
THOUSANDS OF MICHIGAN RESIDENTS
DROVE TO THE STATE CAPITOL IN
LANSING TO EXPRESS THEIR
DISPLEASURE.
THEY DIDN’T HURT ANYONE WHILE
THEY WERE THERE.
THEY DID IT PEACEFULLY, AS IS
THEIR ENSHRINED RIGHT CONSTITUTI
GOVERNOR WHITMER DIDN’T LIKE OUT
IF THERE’S ONE THING
GRETCHEN WHITMER DOESN’T CARE
FOR, IT IS CIVIL DISOBEDIENCE.
ESPECIALLY WHEN IT’S AIMED AT
HER.
AS WITMER EXPLAINED YESTERDAY,
COMPLAINING ABOUT HER DECISIONS
COULD KILL PEOPLE.
>> YOU KNOW COME ON PEOPLE
FLYING THE CONFEDERATE FLAG AND
UNTOLD NUMBERS HAVE GASSED UP ON
THE WAY HERE, GRABBED A BITE ON
THE WAY HOME, WE KNOW THAT THIS
RALLY ENDANGERED PEOPLE.
>> Tucker: WHEN YOU DISAGREE
WITH GRETCHEN WHITMER, YOU
ENDANGER THE PUBLIC.
THAT’S THE NEW STANDARD IN
MICHIGAN.
DEBBIE DINGELL SUPPORTS THAT
STANDARD.
SHE HAS A LONG TIME GM LOBBYIST,
CAR LOBBYIST, WHO INHERITED HER
CONGRESSIONAL SEAT FROM HER
HUSBAND WHO IN TURN INHERITED IT
FROM HIS FATHER.
A DINGELL HAS REPRESENTED FOR 88
YEARS.
THE FAMILY BUSINESSES POLITICS
BUT IT’S REALLY A FORM OF
MONARCHY.
YOU’LL BE SURPRISED TO LEARN
DEBBIE DINGELL IS VERY POPULAR
SOCIALLY IN WASHINGTON.
SHE SHARES WITH HER NEIGHBORS
THEY ARE AN UNDISGUISED LOATHING
FOR THE PEOPLE OF MICHIGAN.
SHE EXPRESSED THAT CONTEMPT THIS
MORNING ON NBC.
>> WHAT HAPPENED YESTERDAY WAS
AN EXCUSABLE PEER PEOPLE DID NOT
HAVE MASKS.
THEY DIDN’T HAVE GLOVES.
THEY DIDN’T DISTANCE THEMSELVES.
THEY HAD CONFEDERATE FLAGS,
SWASTIKAS.
THEY BLOCKED AN ADVIL IS TRYING
TO GET TO A HOSPITAL.
HATE AND FEAR INTO A TIME THAT’S
ALREADY FULL OF FEAR AND
ANXIETY.
IT’S NOT ACCEPTABLE.
THERE WERE PEOPLE BAREHANDED
HANDING CANDY TO CHILDREN.
WHAT THEY DID WAS HELP SPREAD
THIS DISEASE AROUND THE STATE
MORE MOST LIKELY, NOT CONTRIBUTE
INTO THE MITIGATION.
AND IT JUST MADE ME SAD.
>> Tucker: OH, SAD.
DEBBIE DINGELL IS SAD.
SHE IS SAD THE PEOPLE ARE
EXPRESSING INCONVENIENT
POLITICAL BELIEFS WHEN THEY
SHOULD BE DRINKING ALONE AT HOME
OR OBEDIENTLY BUYING MORE
STATE-SPONSORED LOTTO TICKETS.
WHY CAN’T THEY HIT MICHIGAN’S
ENTIRELY ESSENTIAL WHEAT STORES
AND NO AMOUNT, HAS THERE BEEN A
MINUTE LATER GRETCHEN SOLIDIFIES
HER CONTROL OVER THEIR LIVES.
WHY DO THEY HAVE TO COMPLAIN ALL
THE TIME, SAYING UNAPPROVED
THINGS IS RACIST.
IT INSPIRES FEAR AND HATE.
STOP IT RIGHT NOW, YOU PAROLES.